we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P uh here's the Eggman
weighing in about the right Wingers were
like laughing at Joe Biden because he
went to dinner with Jill and they
ordered the same entree it's really
weird and the Eggman called in about it
hi Dave President Joseph R Biden Jr and
his wife Jill went out to dinner
together they ordered the same uh entree
and people are making fun of them for it
or they're being ripped apart basically
I just spilled my water that's what
happened just so you know for eating the
same thing and I just want to say I
think that's adorable that's called I
don't know love or some kind of some
kind of uh
I don't know something together and I
just want to ask do you think Trump even
has a meal
with his wife no
no okay so Eggman weighing in on an
important issue I uh I couldn't possibly
more strongly defend Joe and Jill
ordering the same entree now I think
they had two different appetizers so
that there's that
um personally ordering the same entree
as my girlfriend is a no and the reason
there's actually a really interesting
article uh that's called like the
economics the economics of dining out as
a couple or something like that yes the
it's a Bloomberg article about seven
years old the economics of dining as a
couple
and it explains that one of the great
things one of the great things about
dining out as a couple is you have the
ability to sample multiple dishes it's
very common that at an at a good
restaurant there's more than one thing
that you want and when will you be back
and it's a little bit you know I'm not
going to be ordering two entrees that's
for sure so what I like to do is always
order something different from what my
girlfriend gets so that we can share so
that we can try it and so sometimes I'll
say you know I'm thinking about I'm
thinking about getting the fish and
chips and she'll say I I'm getting the
fish and chips I was like great you get
the fish and chips I will get something
else so now we can try the fish and
chips and we can try the other thing as
far as Joe and Jill Biden doing it more
power to them absolutely more I have no
problem and right Wingers attacking them
for it is a joke we've got a great bonus
show for you today we are going to talk
about Lori Lightfoot losing her bid to
remain mayor of Chicago
we are going to talk about why Americans
will lose three billion dollars in food
stamp benefits starting in March and
Republicans seem to keep forgetting who
the president was in 2020. I'll tell you
what I mean on today's bonus show don't
miss the bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and you will get instant
access to the bonus show that is hated
by conspiracy theorist Alex Jones oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
yeah everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad yeah
joinpakman.com coupon code 24 starts now
I'll see you then